what are your top five
favorite movies of all time i'm curious
we probably we're on the same age so
coming to america okay uh
blank check okay uh
blank check was fire uh hold on
wasn't tone logan blink check uh uh
what's the movie with uh matthew
cunningham matthew mcconaughey matthew
mcconaughey when he played the lawyer
oh samuel j oh uh the about the kkk
yes uh [ __ ] i saw when i was a kid
that was the first time i ever saw the
kkk on tv i was like these [ __ ]
is evil
no bro i forgot it he plays the lawyer
and plays the lawyer
[Music]
that's a hell of a movie that's three of
them uh two more
two more uh
i have to go back uh
goonies goonies is fire ponies
my wife's going is over and over um
the last one [ __ ]
ghost ghost shout out to patrick swayze
patrick swayze dimmer more i'm not gonna
lie you're five
are very they're all i mean i'm a movie
they're a movie head these are all great
movies i got
a thousand movies in my that's how
that's what helps me direct anybody who
watches movies like that you can
directly remember